c'est quoi ton nom mashal
quand la nuit tombe sur la ville
livraison express les divinités déchu
sortent de leurs repères pour suivre le
prince des ténèbres la chasse ne fait
que commencer votre vie et vous qu'est
ce qu'il se fasse ici
face aux forces maléfiques qui menace
l'humanité
monde est plein de surprises mon grand
en est chargée de contrôler toute forme
de vie étrangère qui existerait sans
blake vous prenez pour mellie black
l'écart tient de la nuit sont notre
dernier espoir
ce boulot est sympa ça peut procurer une
bonne dose d'adrénaline
ça ressemble à une grosse farce des
vampires des goules des sorcières je ne
crois pas à tout ça clan contre klan la
guerre entre les humains il est échue va
bientôt éclater
[Musique]
quand vas-tu choisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre avenir est entre leurs mains
maestro semaine les gardiens de la nuit